let's talk about uh Carey Lake because
you know I wanted to talk we got a bunch
of stories to go through but considering
we're still on the political angle let's
let's talk about Kayla we have this
story from azcentral what's next for
Lake fincham election lawsuits hobbs's
lawyer calls challenges baseless so uh
Carey Lake filed the lawsuit contesting
the results of the election a judge
today called an emergency hearing they
had their emergency hearing the defense
which is Maricopa County uh Board of
Supervisors it's uh Katie Hobbs
Democrats basically said that they're
going to file a motion to dismiss but
the judge in the case set a trial date
for I believe uh let me see if I think I
have the Tweet actually if we have it
there we go trial set for the 21st and
the 22nd this is kind of crazy and it's
unfortunate it's going to be happening
over the holiday weekend but this could
be big so here's the difference between
this and Donald Trump's uh 2020 stuff
with Arizona you have a lawsuit from
Cary Lake that points out well or they
make the claim they're 25
000 ballots that came in after election
day and that's greater than the margin
of Victory they want an evidentiary
hearing I don't know how you you you uh
how's the judge gonna say no standing
he's going to say okay show me the proof
you have of this claim they're going to
file a motion to dismiss it very well
may get dismissed I don't know the
difference between this and and Trump to
expand upon that is with a lot of the
lawsuits that were filed in 2020 the
amount of votes that were being
challenged would not have overcome the
victory margin so the courts were just
like
this it wouldn't matter if it happened
anyway so there's no point with Kerry
Lake 17 000 votes so if they can present
a variety of claims that are more than
17 000 and you do have in Maricopa
County they said when the voting
machines malfunctioned 17 000 people had
to vote by this this Ballot Box that's
at bare minimum I think enough to get
well I don't know I mean uh like if you
were being an honest uh a judge you'd be
like okay we have to have a review of
that if 17 000 ballots were were
affected by the machines not working and
that's the margin of Victory we got to
do a review of those ballots otherwise
you know the election is gonna people
are gonna contest or whatever but uh I
think it's interesting nonetheless I
don't know what you guys think my
opinion is kind of that I'm not
convinced Carrie elect going to be able
to overcome the swamp machine so I don't
think that there's I I think that
as much as she is is going to fight
tooth and nail because that's probably
her personality uh I don't think that
it's likely that she's going to be able
to overcome the fact that it was already
certified even though the certification
was you know dubious because what's her
name shouldn't be certified Hobbs is the
Secretary of State the Secretary of
State should not be certifying their own
their own election at all so that right
there is dubious I like but PolitiFact
says it's totally normal oh yeah I I I
think that it's a conflict of interest I
think on its face but I I think that
like I don't think that any of that
stuff matters anymore I've I've lost a
lot of uh faith in the electoral process
so well I'm glad that she's filed soon
I'm glad that she's pursuing it and I
think the Judge absolutely should move
um they should go beyond a motion to
dismiss I mean you go back to the 2000
election right and we didn't have that
result that night and everyone's
freaking out how do we not know who the
president is now with these drop-off
ballots mail-in ballots ballot
harvesting all this I mean election
results taking weeks sometimes yeah it
is not instilling confidence in the
system whatsoever and then also the
question I'd want to know is
how do they determine when and which
ballots are getting cast you know I mean
is that kind of tip the scales a little
bit because maybe somebody calls a race
early
uh you know I don't know but that you
have so many ballots sitting out there I
mean days and sometimes weeks after it
is it really puts uh pressure on the
system and I think it ruins confidence
out there and they like in elections
Democrats completely broke the system
Republicans establishment Republicans in
many places helped but the idea that
we're having election month and and
sometimes even election double month to
election two months because they're
doing a month early and then a month
after the count okay look man if we're
gonna have a functioning system there
have to be rules you can't just be like
the the Democrat position in the leftist
position is count all of the votes and
it's like no no no you count the votes
in the allotted time period And if you
can't then you've got to build a more
robust system to do so we have election
day the Constitution prescribes for
election day we can't be playing these
games where it's like well you know
we'll give it an extra week no no you
don't give it an extra week principally
I agree with with both of you
um
like that's what I would like to see I
think the reality is on the ground uh
are about to prevent that I think yeah I
think that it's going to have to be
ballot harvesting I think it's going to
have to be the the conservatives are
going to have to react to the reality of
what elections are now and you were
talking earlier about you know people
being confident in elections and stuff I
think those days are long past like the
days of of Americans saying oh yeah
generally we feel good about our
election
that is a relics of an old time homie
that stuff is that stuff is gone that
was gone in it was probably gone in 2000
and we didn't realize it until uh I 16.
I blame YouTube largely think so oh
definitely uh look you had half the
country voting one guy half the country
uh voting one guy or whatever whatever
you want to break it down and then
people have questions about what
happened they have ideas they have they
have complaints and then YouTube says
we're only going to allow one side of
the debate oh and so what happened then
is
that large group of people who believed
in Trump left the platform and stopped
communicating with the other side not
not by choice they were forced off
YouTube made sure and maybe it's on
purpose maybe they want everything to
implode or maybe they're just really
dumb
but by segmenting people in that way you
guarantee they entrench their views
never have a conversation it never
develops and then confidence will never
come back never this is what I was
taught when I was talking to Jack and
vagina video I said if you keep doing
what you're doing it's going to result
in some kind of conflict or Civil War or
something you cannot have two people in
an argument
separate them and tell them to keep
arguing about how bad the other side is
but only among themselves that is that
is how you entrench tribalism and it
results in otherism that's where we're
at and you radicalize people that way
exactly and you don't bring the country
together you separate people and you
perpetuate a divide and conquer agenda
which I believe has been festered and
organized deliberately but that's just
my kind of consensus and understanding
of the situation but I I do want to add
to your point Tim especially when it
comes to Big Tech social media because
overwhelmingly 18 to 30 year olds voted
for the Democratic party I do believe
that's because of Institutions like Tick
Tock like Twitter like Google like
Facebook like Instagram that of course
have been prioritizing particular
viewpoints that benefit them with the
political party that benefits them and
censoring the other political parties
that don't benefit them that do want to
have some kind of accountability when it
comes to these bigger institutions but I
think Florida here and shouts out to the
governor of Florida he's making some
very bold and brave Acts actions today
but but I think when we're looking at
Florida there are a lot of lessons to be
learned about the way that they handled
their elections their rules and they
also specifically Ron DeSantis
specifically made sure that Florida
would not be affected by the Zucker
bucks as he called it as Mark Zuckerberg
was financing hundreds of millions of
dollars into the voting effort which
predominantly helped Democrats uh get
more voters he made sure a lot of that
money didn't reach Florida it didn't and
I think it had an impact to it Florida
becoming uh so red so you knew that
result that night neglected results in
Florida that yeah 50 years ago we would
know the results on day one and now now
we it takes days and weeks how's that
possible how is that possible uh let's
see who is this uh Marty Smith
uh fan Sue superintendent saying in AZ
you can't file a dispute until
certification
so after Katie Hobb certifies then
Carrie like immediately launches the
lawsuit and and the middle there's a lot
of interesting uh claims made in the
lawsuit but people need to understand
in a lawsuit you can claim anything you
want
so it's got to be adjudicated it's not
likely in my opinion that Carrie like
just made things up because then you get
to an evidentiary here and you're like
oh that's not true we made it up they're
going to be like okay then you lose so
I'm willing to bet they have something
to present I'd like to see it I I think
what's likely is the judge is just going
to be like I'm too scared of the far
left so I'm not going to actually per
you know let a real Fair hearing take
place but who knows the judge called an
emergency hearing and said we're doing
this they have till Thursday uh
Thursdays when their motion dismisses
due then uh uh Carey Lake gets a
response on Saturday then then the
defendants get a response on Sunday and
then on Monday the judge will have a
hearing and then the trial date is the
21st and 22nd so this is crazy I think
he was like
he has like 10 days to issue a ruling on
this or something like some ridiculously
small amount of time and it's very very
difficult to go through all this it was
funny the uh the the Hobbs defense team
was like we only needed a half an hour
to argue to dismiss this and then Carrie
Lake's team was like no we need more
time than that and the judge was like
what about an hour each it's like I I
think that they're gonna wanna present a
lot of stuff but we'll see
I just also don't understand how okay
like this podcast people watch it all
over the world here we are in this room
they watch it all over the world we
don't have voting machines that work
like why do they keep having problems
with voting machines they can figure out
who uh wait that Powerball that was like
a two billion or whatever it was right
and they're like hundreds of millions of
tickets sold and they know instantly who
won yes
now with these elections though man ever
but but to be fair on that point it's
because everyone's fighting the the real
battle is man if if you thought
elections were won based on how many how
many votes someone got is very naive of
you elections are won based on the
ground game it's one based on the laws
it's one based on like so many
components of this signature
verification mail-in ballots you know
when the ballots come in they got to
check signatures that changes the way
you know it's like it's like Joe Biden
said it's not about how many votes you
get about it's about who counts the vote
is that Joe Biden was it Joe Stalin
there's both okay it literally was both
yeah it actually was both it was both so
here we are this is the the current
state I guess you know a lot of people I
don't think care too much about the uh I
don't think as many people are following
this because the midterms have come and
gone and everyone's kind of zoned out
like exhausted from it
but while I'm not confident for Carrie
Lake and I'm a big fan I want her to win
I do think it would be really
interesting if she actually does win a
stay at the very least yeah and then
come January 2nd they're like oh we
actually can't we can't bring in you
know Hobbs as Governor because of the
stage should buy a court
yeah I mean I'd like to I'd like to see
it just because I'd like to see the the
you know the non-establishment
um candidates win because I think the
establishment uh needs some fresh
refreshing
uh of idl's ideology I suppose
um but yeah I I don't I just don't see
her pulling it off I don't I don't see
the powers that be in in Arizona you
know well I think I think maybe we're a
bit pessimistic because of what you know
we've seen in the past but uh I'm fully
likes fighting and so I'm rooting for
I'm rooting for her too I wanna I all I
want to see is the judge say show me the
evidence and then if they present bunk
garbage or it's weak and the judge says
I'm sorry it's not enough then I'm gonna
say well okay I guess but uh it needs to
get to that point because we haven't
seen that with these these other uh
lawsuits yeah yeah no no standing get
out yeah they just get thrown out I mean
this one needs to go the distance and
look transparency is a good thing that
instills confidence let's have some
transparency in this and see actually
what happened to those 17 000 ballots
why the machines weren't working perhaps
what happened to those ballots they said
they were all counted yeah well I want
to know that they were all counted right
they they should do uh they should they
should go through and signature verify
whatever if and I'll put it this way too
let's say you operate on the assumption
that Kerry lake is just totally wrong
then here's your opportunity to prove it
and rub it in her face well and the
annoying thing is that because you're
going through this process or you
believe this process should happen the
left is like election denial or you all
are in election deniers election tonight
it's like no what we want this is a good
thing right however it turns out this is
a good thing that could perhaps instill
a little bit uh more confidence in the
electoral process hopefully yeah as much
as people as much as the left says you
know that there's that election denial
is bad and blah blah blah blah they're
doing everything they can
to make sure that their opposition
doesn't have any faith in the in the
election they're throwing out all all
kinds of court cases saying without
standing they never get in front of a
judge they have they have all you know
they're saying that if you deny the
election or if you if you ask for
verification it's election denying
they're doing everything they can to
make people feel like the elections
should be suspect yeah well this is what
the left does with everything right it's
their solution is always worse than the
problem right so people had uh you know
there's voter suppression and people
don't have a confidence in elections so
now we're gonna have elections last for
a month right and it's just it made it
worse it just made things even worse it
just made things even worse I mean it's
like when they raise taxes it's like
well then we'll just come up with more
taxes and we'll fix it well let's see
what happens on uh next Monday is when
they're gonna be uh I guess the judge
will issue a ruling but then eight days
from now 21st and 22nd is the trial date
if it makes it that far should be very
interesting thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time